rachid digoin qui est infirmier au bloc
opératoire du centre hospitalier william
morey président du collectif inter blocs
dont jours à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous votre réaction à cette journée
de heurts dans la capitale lors de cette
journée de mobilisation
écoutez je découvre les images un peu un
tango puisque moi jeu était plutôt en
local où ça s'est très bien passé où il
ya eu une manifestation plutôt pacifique
malheureusement c'est je pense des
dérives limité puisqu'ils ne font pas
les soignants qui sont qui sont mis en
cause mais bon malheureusement ça fait
partie des mouvements glaives et des
droits sociaux
on le regrette malheureusement ça
entache un peu là la forte mobilisation
et aujourd'hui c'est dommage sur les
revendications des personnels soignants
cette journée elle est importante
à quelles raisons en ce moment et ce
parce que c'est du rhin où a priori tout
tout se joue malheureusement on ne sait
pas partie de la liste des invités nous
avons été sollicités au départ pour le
lancement mais malheureusement on a été
mis sur la touche notamment une grosse
partie des organisations inspiré mer on
le regrette aujourd'hui c'était
important de se mobiliser de de
manifester notre notre colère ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce qui prédomine
assez la colère des soignants et est
d'être dans la rue et d'imposer de
renvendiquer rapport de force par
rapport à ce gouvernement qui nous
méprise depuis depuis trop longtemps
ce gouvernement qui tente en tout cas de
trouver des solutions tous azimuts on
sait qu'on traverse ne traversent
toujours cette crise sanitaire
à cela s'ajoute une crise économique
d'envergure
on est dans un cas de figure qui est
quand même différent par rapport à au
début de l'année 1
même avant lorsque vous avez des
revendications c'est vrai que la crise
économique elle frappe fort
le gouvernement il a publié ce week end
et décret qui entérine le versement
d'une prime exceptionnelle à 2000 à 1500
euros pour les salariés des ehpad une
majoration également de 50% des heures
supplémentaires effectuées à l'hôpital
qui seront normalement payer avant le
mois de septembre sur ces mesures qui
interviennent avant les réponses
attendues en juillet qu'est ce que vous
dites
la prime malheureusement c'est parce
qu'on réclame depuis le début on sait
très bien que cette prime allait
distribuer de façon injuste nous c'était
des revendications ça des
revalorisations salariales pour qu on
réclame depuis le début des
mobilisations dit que le contexte est
particulier malheureusement le coc vide
il a mis en évidence toute la structure
qui est qui s'écoulait de l'hôpital
public
c'est ce que l'on retient aujourd'hui
c'est pas c'est pas d'aujourd'hui ça
fait dix quinze vingt ans que on pioche
dans les caisses de l'hôpital public
pour la fait venir aujourd'hui c'est la
crise du coville qui est qui qui reflète
tout ce manque mais malheureusement on
peut pas dire que c'est que d'afrique au
vide on voit que les hôpitaux sont ans
élu depuis garçons longtemps et cette
colère elle et voilà elle est dissimulée
par tous à la crise du coc vide
justement elle fait l'objet d'auditions
en cours
lors d'une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale
commission qui a débuté ses travaux cet
après midi à 17 heures avec l'audition
de jérôme salomon le directeur général
de la santé là encore ça coïncide aussi
avec cette journée d'action nationale
c'est un hasard du calendrier ou pas
vous pensez je pense hasard du
calendrier je pense qu'elle était prévue
depuis depuis d'appeler longtemps d'où
ce conte par rapport à ces à cette
enquête 1 on a le collectif inter bloc a
mis une plainte au pénal sur 32
établissements 32 chu en france puisque
on compte bien avoir un retour au niveau
des comtés de tout ce qui s'est passé
tous les manquements auquel on a pu
faire face notamment aux face aux
équipes pros manque d'équipements de
protection
vous êtes toujours avec nous merci
d'ailleurs vous avez entendu à l'instant
anne hidalgo est ce que c'est ces propos
font écho
à ce qui se passe aujourd'hui à paris
ils ont toute l'aviation immersion ça
fait coincer la ligne de conduite
contient depuis le début ainsi demandé
des moyens pour les hôpitaux des moyens
financiers des moyens humains puisque la
plaie de coheed a révélé que on a manqué
de bras il ya fallu réaménager des blocs
opératoires en réanimation donc ont
manqué d'animations à ce qui ce qui
était quand même très problématique
pendant cette crise
en fait la surprise à l'arrivée vraiment
au manque de moyens et c'est vrai que
madame hidalgo elle parle de recentrer
sur lui 20 c est eux mangent ce qu'on
demande aux 6 et c'est celle de l'huma
remettre l'humain au coeur au coeur des
établissements de santé
vous restez avec nous on va vous montrer
des images ces images fortes de tension
aujourd'hui entre les forces de l'ordre
et les manifestants
regardez cette manifestante en blouse
que l'on voit ici
et bien c'est certainement une
professionnelle de la santé elle a
brutalement été percutée par une charge
des forces de l'ordre d'une violente une
illustration de ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui en marque donc de cette
manifestation à des soignants qui a
dégénéré cet après midi comment vous
réagissez
lorsque vous voyez ce type d'image c'est
terrible je pense d'abord à ma collègue
après je pense que c'est parce qu'il
faut aller les violences et parce qu'il
faut retenir je pense qu'il ya eu une
très grosse mobilisation aujourd'hui que
ce soit du côté des soignants aider la
population qu'on peut remercier une
nouvelle fois et je pense que c'est ce
qu'il faut retenir ce gros mouvement
s'est aussi unité nationale qui s'est
faite autour des soignants pour m'aider
moyens dans l'hôpital public et plus
largement dans les établissements de
santé
quand on voit que les manifestations se
déroulent toujours avec beaucoup de
difficultés elles sont émaillés de
heurts cette manifestation deux de vos
confrères mais pas seulement on a vu les
des scènes de violence lors des
manifestations des gilets jaunes tout
récemment je le disais tout à l'heure
lors d'une manifestation pour dénoncer
les violences policières présumées le
racisme au sein des forces de l'ordre
qu'est ce que vous vous dites on
entendait tout à l'heure l'un de nos
invités lui ont pointé la responsabilité
du didier lallement le le préfet de
police
écoutez il ya une stabilité en tout cas
gouvernemental c'est comme dans notre
secteur on n'est pas écoutés on se sent
méprisée
donc à un moment donné les gens les gens
sont en colère donc vu qu'il n'ya pas
possibilité d'avoir de discussion avec
avec toutes ces personnes haut placées
et basse et la colère c'est la violence
s'exprime malheureusement on en arrive à
des points des fois ils sont critiqués
cc c'est regrettable en tout cas qu'il
n'y ait pas un espace de discussion ou
une écoute de la part du gouvernement
tout casser c'est ce qu'on peut
regretter quand on voit ces violences la
préfecture de police qui a réagi sur
twitter on l'a dit cet après midi elle
appelle à nouveau au calme
voici son tweet des individus violents
n'ont pas leur place dans une
manifestation pacifique et
l'administration également informé qu'à
17 heures 24 interpellations ont donc
été enregistrés ces deux derniers bilans
à 17 heures
on compte donc 24 interpellations ainsi
des doigts vous êtes toujours avec nous
peut-être vous voulez réagir sur ce
twitt de la préfecture de paris complet
on peut être que d'accord avec cela il
faut il faut appeler au calme
il faut que les choses voilà ce
temporise après quand je faisais une
grosse colère non plus noté également de
notre côté une grosse colère de remercie
les établissements et les directions
notamment qui ont assigné le personnel à
100 % notamment dans certains blocs
opératoires comme au chu de dijon à
pouvoir motors- enfin je pourrais vous
en citer énormément donc je vous parlais
de colère la colère elle exprime aussi
de ce côté-là part des directions qui
prive les personnels soignants de leur
droit de grève et ça aujourd'hui c'est
inadmissible donc on voudrait aussi le
christ sur vos plateaux 7 cette manière
de faire de nos établissements
mais où pour revenir à cette
manifestante tout à l'heure qui a été
renversée 1
entre les lords haute tension entre les
forces de l'ordre et les manifestants on
aurait pu éviter cela peut-être qu'en
pensez vous à écouter en tout cas
n'avait pas l'air très très menaçante ou
je ne sais pas si c'était pas je n'étais
pas dans le contexte et après c'est
difficile pour moi d'interpréter sur des
images mais bon voilà a priori elle
était chargée malheureusement je pense
sens plutôt à aider et à sa famille dans
un premier temps c'est vrai que la
situation aujourd'hui à déraper on peut
le regretter
on va quand même peut-être un mot quand
même sur ce qui s'est passé en province
parce que c'est vrai qu'à paris à des
manifestations qui ont dégénéré on l'a
suivi tout cet après midi mais en
prenant ça s'est bien passé je suis en
tout cas c'était très très pacifique
on a des retours des territoires qui
sont très positif c était une grosse
mobilisation aussi dans les territoires
ce qu'il faut noter un très pacifiste
donc on est on est très satisfaits de
cette journée qui est qui est une
première parmi tant d'autres puisqu'il
ya déjà d'autres dates qui sont
annoncées notamment celle du 30 juin et
7 peut-être du 14 juillet où on va se
focaliser sur celle là et continuer la
lutte
malheureusement envers ce gouvernement
quitte une envolée prises ou le disiez
tout à l'heure qui aurait une nouvelle
journée de manifestation le 30 juin
probablement le 14 juillet n'est pas le
seul à avoir annoncé ces deux journées
cet après midi sur notre antenne est ce
qu'il faut craindre de nouveaux
débordements
pour les prochaines journées de
mobilisation en tout cas on espère on
espère que l'on a vu malheureusement
tient un port de force qui s'est fait
dans la violence aujourd'hui
malheureusement pour eux le regretté en
tous cas la volonté de tous les
soignants et des ceux qui se mobilisent
et l'usagé ce n'est pas du tout la
violence c est pacifique et de
revendiquer nos droits dans dans un
calme précis donc personnellement je
crains pas du tout un regard de violence
sur les prochaines la mobilisation alors
c'est aujourd'hui d'actions nationales
elles répondaient à l'appel d'une
dizaine de syndicats de collectifs de
deux soignants est ce que vous appelez
osciller les français à venir manifester
avec vous le 30 juin prochain
peut-être le 14 juillet on a vu beaucoup
de gilet jaune aussi présents
aujourd'hui
bien sûr je sais c'est un combat qui les
concerne aussi bien on sait que
l'hôpital public
si la prise en charge du public se fait
notamment d'aurea dans le secteur du
public à la grosse partie sans sans
distinction donc ce qu'on valait
concerne donc on les appelle tout autant
que les soignants à venir réclamer des
moyens pour l'hôpital public on ça va
coïncider à peu près avec les réponses
attendues dans le cadre du ségur de la
santé aussi ce sera probablement son
mois de juillet
est ce que à ce niveau là justement vous
avez des d'espoir de voir enfin le
système de santé français se relancer
alors quand même hein bien sûr il ya eu
un court essai d'avants de la part du
gouvernement comment voulez-vous que en
quelques semaines en ressent d'un
système de santé en entier sait c'est
impossible c'est surtout que le
gouvernement n'a annoncé clairement au
niveau du ségur aucun budget pour
l'hôpital est ce que vous avez entendu
combien allait investir le gouvernement
dans l'hôpital encore entendus pour le
touriste pour l'aéronautique pour
l'europe et pour les hôpitaux n'a
entendu du tout donc on peut que
s'étonner de ces négociations qui dit je
pense la mèneront à rien puisque une
partie en tout cas des désorganisations
qu'on vous présente n'a pas été convié à
ce c'est dur on s'explique toujours
pourquoi et eon dogon pose la question
gouvernement aujourd'hui pourquoi ils
nous ont invités au lancement puisque à
priori on était légitime pour y
participer à ce lancement est pas pour
les suit un chiffre ou en tête que vous
pourriez avoir pour relancer le système
de santé tout à l'heure on entendait ce
chiffre 15 milliards d'euros
je pense qu'on était je pense que la
tête et plus sur les 30 milliards donc
après il faudrait bien plus que cela
toute façon ça fait ça fait des années
qu'on a parlé à rester dans les hôpitaux
donc malheureusement ou après après un
chiffre qui je pense dépasse dépasse les
30 milliards d'euros c'est certain
surtout après la crise du coc vide on
sait que l'établissement était très
attendu puisqu'il n'ont pas eu
d'activité ils ont dû réinvestir dans
des dans des matériaux qui n'avaient pas
notamment dans des respirateurs dans du
matériel de protection
donc tout ça c'est un coup donc ça tout
ça va être ajoutées à la note des
établissements puisque c'est les
établissements qui vont en pâtir
donc aujourd'hui on se pose vraiment la
question de ce que le gouvernement
préconise pour pour les hôpitaux et les
établissements de santé en général
en ce moment on le rappelle jérôme salon
le directeur général de la santé il est
entendu par la commission d'enquêté
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale
ça se déroule en ce moment à un moment
nous nous parlons cette commission
denquête ce ségur de la santé ces
manifestations dans la rue c'est le même
combat finalement c'est pas dit assez
tout est dit et c'est clair mais je
pense qu'il faut prendre chaque problème
par rapport à du social renoncer c'est
une affaire de vente mans par rapport à
tout tous les équipements de protection
toute cette gestion du cockpit donc
cette cette gestion a mis à une certaine
colère et a rajouté une colère au niveau
des soignants ça c'est certain
par rapport à tout ce qu'on a vécu par
rapport à l'afrique au vide 1 je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il a une cause vidal est
décriée notamment je vous parlais d'un
cas sur le chu de toulouse où ou la
direction s'octroie la prime de 1500
euros alors qu'elle va donner à son
personnel uniquement les 500 euros donc
si vous voulez c'est c'est tout ce
contexte là que aujourd'hui on bien on
vient revendiquer c'est plus possible de
continuer comme ça avec des directions
qui sont complètement déconnectés de la
réalité
enfin la colère elle est certaine les
soignants en tout cas ce sont arrêterons
pas là
donc ce que vous dites c'est que s'il
faut réformer le système de santé il
faut commencer il faut évidemment de
l'argent c'est le nerf de la guerre mais
il faut aussi repenser une organisation
nouvelle a bien sûr et surtout fossé il
faut solliciter les agents du terrain
aujourd'hui quand on parle de la crise
du combi de ce ne sont pas les ars qui
nous ont qui nous ont dicté commencer un
ce sont les équipes qui sont organisés
en interne pour tout réorganiser le
système de prise en charge des patients
donc si vous voulez il ya une
déconnexion totale entre on va dire les
hautes sphères et le terrain donc si
monsieur vers en a parlé de retour
d'expérience au lancement du c'est dur
et bien qu'il appelle les gens du
terrain et qu'il leur fasse confiance
eux aussi et aujourd'hui on représente
ces personnes des terrains donc vous
attendait des réponses concrètes pour
réconcilier les gens du terrain et les
hautes sphères comme vous dites si bien
sûr bien sûr on attend des réponses
concrètes et surtout on attend que en
le gouvernement sollicite les bonnes
personnes qui sont ces bonnes personnes
selon vous les acteurs du terrain c'est
ce que j'ai à vous dire les infirmiers
et aides soignants les médecins tous les
corps qui ont participé à la gestion de
la crise et qu'il connaisse exactement
l'ampleur de ce qu'il faut réaliser en
termes d'organisation pour remettre sur
pied à l'hôpital public qui souffrent
énormément
vous vous avez vous ressenti une
déconnexion beaucoup plus forts de cette
fiche sanitaire entre ces hautes sphères
que vous dénoncez et les gens du terrain
bien sûr j'ai juste un exemple on a eu
des retours de collègue anesthésiste qui
sont partis à la grèce notamment fait
les plans blancs ont été déclenchées
peut penser arrivé et que ça on allait
leur sortie rappelant tous et pour
l'organisation est en fait ils ont dû
tout mettre en oeuvre
donc si vous voulez y avait rien de
préparé et c'est ce que je vous disais
c'est les équipes qui sont mis à pied
d'oeuvre pour tout organiser donc c'est
sûr qu'elle déconnexion totale entre les
agents du terrain et les hautes sphères
ça c'est clair et net
l'avenir de du système de santé français
est ce que réellement vous êtes
optimiste disons qu'on a quand même une
touche d'optimisme puisqu'on voit les
mobilisations aujourd'hui qui ont été
actives a été énorme donc on a espoir on
a espoir d'être entendu et d'instaurer
ce sera pour deux sens puisque
malheureusement il ya que ça qui peut
dire ça entend aujourd'hui on leur dette
on le regrette qu'on soit pas écouté
conçoit pas pris au sérieux et que les
premiers de cordée comme on nous appelle
les infirmiers les aides soignants soit
pris en compte
heure par heure soit pris en compte il
n'y a pas que la parole des médecins
parlent d'abord des médecins s'est par
rapport au collectif inter hôpitaux qui
était intronisé au c'est dur et pas et
pas les autres collectifs de soignants
par exemple quand ceux ci qui peut
aboutir en la vie sur des manifestations
qui dégénèrent ce qu'il faut prendre ce
risque
encore et encore disons que ce que vous
avez une solution vous pour nous à
l'apparat par la rue puisqu'il n'y a pas
et il n'y a pas d' écoute il n'y a pas
de avec le gouvernement il ya propose
possibilité de se faire entendre
donc malheureusement donc c'est de
sortir dans la rue pour vous nous
annonciez tout à l'heure de nouvelles
manifestations le 30 juin le 14 juillet
peut-être est-ce qu'il faudra
s'organiser au niveau des personnels
soignants cette fois pour éviter des
débordements même si on sait il y aura
encore des forces de l'ordre qui seront
mobilisés pour encadrer ces
rassemblements pourquoi je pense que il
y avait déjà une organisation n'a -
puisque les services d'ordre de toutes
les organisations syndicales étaient
présents donc je pense que de ce côté là
tout le monde était réglo après
peut-être revoir je sais pas au niveau
des cortèges à savoir peut-être
différencier je ne sais pas les âges et
des soignants malheureusement
aujourd'hui un dans les images que je
vois aujourd'hui c'est pas beaucoup j'ai
pas beaucoup vu deux pouces blanches
dans dans l'erreur donc est-ce que c'est
uniquement la population est-ce que
c'est uniquement les soignants je ne
sais pas je peux pas vous dire comme ça
je participe à la sp participer
je ne participait pas à la manifestation
vous n'avez pas participé à la
manifestation on le rappelle il ya eu
oui à paris a eu donc des échauffourées
qui ont éclaté en marge de cette
manifestation des soignants avec déjà
deux projets deux projectiles et les
forces de l'ordre ont répliqué à coups
de gaz lacrymogènes on compte 24
interpellations selon un dernier bilan
de la préfecture de police et de
nombreux blessés également peut-être
aussi d'aider de nombreux manifestants
qui ont été blessés tout à l'heure on a
montré et vous les avez commenter avec
nous ces images d'une dune confrère qui
a été prise à parti pris on va dire
entre les forces de l'ordre et les
manifestants
mais c'est vrai que c'est malheureux de
voir mes collègues se faire charger de
la sorte
malheureusement la violence était au
rendez vous aujourd'hui de part et
d'autre donc a priori que faire pour les
prochaines c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué pour nous c'est compliqué on
sait qu' il ya un mouvement social une
contestation donc ça peut faire partie
malheureusement des débordements alors
un mot peut-être sur l'état d'esprit des
personnels soignants dans ces personnels
soignants il ya des médecins il ya des
infirmiers il ya des brancardiers
j'essaie de soignants des gens qui sont
donc on a beaucoup vu à pied d'oeuvre
durant cette crise sanitaire au plus
fort de cette crise
qu'est-ce qui domine aujourd'hui je
parlais de cet état d'esprit et ce qui
est de la colère mais ça va ou même au
delà de la colère est ce que vous vous
ressentez qu'il peut y avoir une forme
de radicalisation aussi des personnels
soignants
enfin une colère qui se radicalise plus
tôt je parlerai pas de radicalisation
c'est pas du tout avec multi en tout cas
tous les soignants c'est pas de vos
valeurs aujourd'hui il ya une colère
il ya aussi une fatigue psychologique
c'était très intense tout ce qu'on a
vécu donc par la suite je pense qu'il y
aura des traumatismes par rapport à
toutes ces prises en charge pour qu'on a
pu avoir qu'on a pu faire ça ce sera
dans le temps qu'on va le revoir enfin
combat pour elle reconnaître donc
malheureusement est ce qu'on va perdre
des collègues
après tout cette crise est ce qu'il y
aura un après pour l'hôpital parce que
quand vous avez vu le manque de moyens
n'est pas très attrayant pour les jeunes
avec qui voudraient s'orienter dans la
voie du milieu de la santé
donc aujourd'hui ça c'est encore tout
frais mais je pense que on va en faire
les frais dans non je pense dans six
mois un an
mieux le dialogue il est toujours à
l'ordre du jour quand je parlais de
durcissement justement de cet état
d'esprit des personnels soignants c'est
peut-être aussi un le ras-le-bol qui
domine parce que ces revendications on
les entend depuis des années ah ben
c'est pas foot c'est pas faute de les
répéter à nos revendications à ccc
toujours les mêmes pour tous cas il ya
un socle commun de l'apport de tous les
soignants après chaque fois chaque
organisation a ses spécificités interne
ou pour les deux opérateurs mais en tout
cas il ya un socle commun qui est très
claire et est malheureusement comme je
disais tout à l'heure on n'a pas d'
écoute de la part du gouvernement donc
c'est sûr que on sait plus comment
réagir face à ces ça c'est certain
au delà des des revendications de cette
journée spéciale pour les personnels
soignants
ce qu'on constate avec ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui est cet après midi à
paris c'est qu'on ne peut plus
manifester
je veux dire sans violences dans la
capitale particulièrement c'est sûr que
c'est ça a l'air très compliqué
entretien c'est parce que c'est parce
qu'on ressent du côté des deux côtés de
la province alors peut-être qu'il
faudrait délocaliser les manifestations
en province
blague à part mais oui c'est sûr que il
ya une colère sociale qui est très
importante il ya pas plus secteur de la
santé qui a impacté il ya beaucoup de
secteurs donc malheureusement ça
s'explique comme cela aussi on peut
regretter la violence de part et d'autre
il faut il faut des condamnés pour pas
on va voir ce genre de situation ça
c'est une manifestation c'est qu'il
s'est déroulé alors qu'on est en face de
déconfinement plutôt avancé mais il ya
quand même un risque quand même
lakovic 19 n'a pas disparu en france
tout à fait là pas disparu d'ailleurs il
ya même un des clusters qui sont un peu
réapparu à l'étranger aussi notamment
donc il faut rester très prudent je vois
que les maisons barrières on était quand
même respecter avec le port du masque
il n'y a pas eu forcément peut-être la
distanciation dans quels cas de port du
masque je pense l'hygiène des mains a
été respectée en tout cas d'un autre
cadre en province a été très très
respectée donc oui c'est sûr qu'on en
perde de déconfinement il faut il faut
rester vigilant puisqu'on sait que la
mairie de la véracité de ce virus n'est
plus à prouver aujourd'hui et on ne
connaît pas assez encore pour dire que
tout est fini
alors en juillet donc ce sera encore un
mois qui va être chargé
tant sur le plan des revendications des
personnels soignants mais mais ça ira
peut-être au-delà cette vague de grogne
sociale
ce défi aussi de la relance et
économique en france
elle complique la tâche des autorités
dans ce contexte là finalement est-ce
qu'il faut pas faire preuve de patience
et de retenue
côté je pense que mon à exprimer notre
colère depuis bien trop longtemps on l'a
on va essayer de museler
maintenant c'est fini on va rendre
beaucoup de choses donc aujourd'hui il
faut nous laisser la place il faut il
faut nous nous accueillir dans les
négociations
temporiser ce serait laisser le temps au
gouvernement malheureusement alors qu'
il ya beaucoup de solutions et on sait
aujourd'hui qu'il existe beaucoup de
finances dans certains domaines donc il
faudrait peut-être revoir une
redistribution et il ya beaucoup de
solutions a en tout cas à étayer
on va terminer avec vous sur les
principales revendications qu'il faut
retenir de cette journée de
manifestation ça concerne l'augmentation
des salaires plus de moyens en termes de
ressources humaines mais aussi l'arrêt
de la suppression des délits notamment
vous pouvez vous nous révéler le coeur
de revendications c'est exactement ça
c'est des moyens humains financiers
l'arrêt des fermetures de lits l'arrêt
des structures d'établissements
notamment remettre le patient au coeur
du système de soins et que
l'organisation soit aussi tripartite
avec les soignants et les médecins et la
direction
et pour conclure vous pensez qu'on va
tirer les leçons
de cette crise sanitaire de la copie de
19 en tout cas du côté des soignants il
ya un retour d'expérience donc on va
tirer beaucoup de leçons de tout ce qui
s'est passé
malheureusement je ne serais pas aussi
affirmatif du côté du gouvernement
notamment avec des comportements des
directions qui repartent d'un la hausse
dans l'ancien temps acquis qui abusent
de leur pouvoir malheureusement donc de
ce côté là on peut quand même être
plutôt pessimiste merci à vous rachid de
digoin d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes ainsi renié au
bloc opératoire du centre hospitalier
william morey président du collectif
inter bloc merci à vous